sir all 20 cities in the case-shiller
index reported higher home prices than
they did a year ago how then would you
characterize the state of the US housing
market you know it's growing the story
should be much better we have we have
five and a half percent unemployment we
have 30 or fixed-rate mortgages still
just a little below 4% we have home
prices increasing the biggest growth
we're seeing today quite frankly is in
new home sales which are forecasted to
be up about 13 percent year-over-year
existing homes are growing at a slower
pace but what's affecting prices
primarily today is inventory there's
just not a lot of affordable inventory
in the market
that's not meeting the demand that's
causing some home price increases
particularly in urban markets where most
of the employment growth is happening
mr. Stevens David Blitzer the chairman
of the SP Index committee he noted today
home prices are rising roughly twice as
fast as wages are if the Federal Reserve
raises interest rates mid-year as many
economists expect what will that mean
for price gains in the housing market
well we've forecast
mortgage rates to rise anyway our
forecast today is to have interest rates
level off at about four point six
percent by the end of the year compared
to what we're seeing today at about
three point nine nine percent which is
today's 30 or fixed-rate average from
our perspective that does not change the
demand for housing household formation
is really a core component here and it's
growing at a significant post recession
rate at a level that's far more
normalized compared to where we were a
few years ago that's just going to
create a demand for more units both
rental an owner-occupied and so we
believe that the housing market can
withstand some modest increases in
interest rates sir with tight supply
driving up home prices then how
concerned are you that many would-be
buyers are still being priced out of
this market well it is it is a
significant concern and as I said
earlier a lot of the employment gains
have been made in larger metropolitan
markets like Washington in New York and
San Francisco etc that's where the
housing shortages are most severe and so
the question is will new build or
inventory new supply
inventory help meet that demand because
if not we're going to see a lot of
household formation focused more on
rental housing than owner-occupied
housing and we'll see the real
owner-occupied housing growth in
subprime cities or second-level
second-tier cities where that where the
affordability factors are far more
positive for potential homebuyers mr.
Stevens the rental vacancy rate at the
end of last year it was at 7% how much
pressure is this putting on rents and
will it be enough to make renters
reconsider buying a home well the
challenge is at the end of the day is if
you can't get access to credit or if you
have trepidation about concerns about
your future stability in your job
situation you're gonna delay making that
buying decision we're seeing that
clearly today so to your point the
vacancy rate is at 7% it was at 11% a
year ago that's creating stress on
affordable rental housing that has an
impact of actually pushing long term
renters who likely aren't going to be
homebuyers into a much less affordable
lifestyle as landlords raise rents
because of the demand cycle that we're
facing so all of this is problematic
it's a tipping of the pendulum a little
too far towards the rental side and when
that imbalance gets out of whack we get
an imbalance in homeownership mister
seems we have a little less than a
minute left the Joint Center for Housing
it expects two thirds of all household
formation going forward next decade to
be minority what's the significance of
that not just for the housing market but
for the overall US economy yes so
particularly in the Latino community
which is so important to housing demand
in this country they're making up a
significant portion of new housing
starts that are happening new household
formation that is happening in this
country the homeownership rate in the
Hispanic community and the
african-american community is
approximately 45 to 46 percent and so
that will have a depressing value on
overall homeownership rates it'll create
more pressure on rental housing so
getting that balance right making sure
that credit policy the cost of housing
and job gains are equally felt across
all community
in this country has a big economic
impact ultimately on housing